[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
هالوين وملابس تنكريه احتفالات براس السنه
الميلاديه ونجوم غناء عالميين على المسرح
وكريستيانو رونالدو في نادي النصر دروس
سينما ممتلئه كارا اوكي ورفع الحظر عن
تطبيق تندر هنا الرياض عاصمه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه مملكه منذ ان كانت تشددت
في الاحتكام للشريعه على ارض مكه مهدي
الاسلام
لكن رجلا لقب بسيد كل شيء اتاها برؤيه
مختلفه نحو الاعتدال والتحرر من التطرف
والانفتاح كما يقول هو ولي العهد محمد بن
سلمان بطل في عيون البعض ومشروع ديكتاتور
في عيون اخرين فهل يقلب انبئس قواعد
اللعبه فعلا ام ان هدفه هو العرش هل يتغير
كل شيء في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
استعدادا لمرحله ما بعد النفط ام انها
تحولات سطحيه اتت ارضاء للغرب السعوديه في
ظل اصلاحات محمد بن سلمان في فلك الممنوع
[موسيقى]
اختلاط موسيقى صاخبه واجساد راقصه مشهد لم
تعرفه ارض الحرمين كما يسميها البعض فمنذ
نشاتها تتبنى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اسلاما وهابيا
وتنصب نفسها بوصله للمسلمين في كل العالم
لم تخلع السعوديه عباءتها الدينيه
المتشدده الا مؤخرا مع رجل رفع شعار
الاسلامي المعتدل محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد
الطموح
تحديث بلاده فكما يذكر دائما السعوديه
مملكه شابه
غالبيه سكانها من الشباب
انا اعتقد
ان اوروبا الجديده هي الشرق الاوسط
[تصفيق]
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في الخمس سنوات
القادمه سوف تكون مختلفه تماما البحرين
على طريقه بن سلمان كان مستحيلا دون ملفات
النساء الحقوقيه ففي يونيو 2018 منحنا
الحق بقياده سياره بعد ذلك سمح لهن بتاسيس
الشركات دون اذن من ولي الامر كما جرت
العاده
فاصبح من السهل دخولهن سوق العمل
لتراجع نسبيا سيطره الدوله على النساء عن
طريق نظام الولايه
سلسله اصلاحات جراده الشرطه الدينيه من
صلاحياتها وانهت الفصل الالزاميه بين
الجنسين في الاماكن العامه اذا نظريا في
مملكه محمد بن سلمان ثوره حقوقيه لمصلحه
النساء وسياسه انفتاح بعد ان ولا زمن
الامر بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر
لكن في عهد صاحب رؤيه 2030 للمملكه وجون
اخر اعتقالات بالجمله واعدامات واخفاء
قصري وتكميم للافواه سيناريو مثلا ليس من
الزمن البعيد في نوفمبر 2017 تحول هذا
الفندق الشهير في مشهد الهوليودي وبين
ليله وضحاها الى حبس للرجال اعمال ورؤساء
حكومات وسياسيين وامراء والحجه مكافحه
الفساد
عام بعد ذلك تم تصفيه الصحفي جمال خاشقجي
في جريمه هزت ببشاعتها كل العالم وكادت ان
تعصف بالعهد الجديد في السعوديه حرب محمد
بن سلمان ووالده على المعارضه لم تهدا في
الداخل كما في الخارج تهديدات واتهامات
بالخيانه العظمى ومحاولات حديثه للهيمنه
على كل دوائر الحكم
فكيف لنظام ذي وجهين ان يصنع اوروبا جديده
كما يعمل محمد بن سلمان
[موسيقى]
اصلاحاته محمد بن سلمان بعيون نساء معرضات
سعوديات هي زاويه التي نطرحها عليكن
وعليكم اليوم في فلك الممنوع خمس شابات
لديهن تجارب مختلفه في اطر حقوقيه متنوعه
غادرنا المملكه العربيه السعوديه بتذكره
ذهاب بدون اياب وفي الجزء الاول من حلقتنا
اخترنا ان نسالهن في ظل الاصلاحات
والانفتاح هل باتت العوده الى ارض الوطن
ممكنه وسابدا مع لينا الهذول رئيسه قسم
الرصد والمناصره في منظمه القسط لحقوق
الانسان اهلا بك لينا انت
شقيقه الناشطه السعوديه لوجين التي اعتقلت
عام 2018 وباتت الف ليله وليله في السجون
السعوديه وتعرضت للتعذيب وللكثير من
الانتهاكات اطلق سراحها في فبراير 2021
وهي ممنوعه من السفر مع باقي افراد الاسره
اليوم انت لينا الهذول هل
تظنين ان عهد الاصلاحات قد يسمح لك
بالعوده الى ديارك
اعتقد لو ارجع للسعوديه
ياخذوني الى السجن على طول نشوف مثلا سلمى
الشهاب تهمه بالارهاب واحكموا عليها 34
عام بالسجن بسبب اعاده تغريداتي انا
فاعتقد انه يعني
رغم كل ما يحدث اليوم انت لا يمكنك العوده
بسبب مواقفك السياسيه او بسبب مواقفك
المعارضه طيب ساعود اليك وساسال هذا
السؤال ايضا لضيفاتنا الاخريات نتعرف
عليهن
اميمه النجار انت ناشطه حقيقيه وانت ايضا
يعني اعتقلتي سابقا في
لم اعتقل انا كنت مشارك تم توقيفك في بسبب
مشاركتك بحمله اثناء المظاهرات لما كنا
بقياده السياره بالضبط وغادرت السعوديه
عام 2012
مزبوط للقدوم للجوء في ايطاليا طيب في
الصين فاولا في الصين ومن ثم اتيت الى
اوروبا اعاده توطين في ايطاليا تمام انت
اليوم طالبه دراسات عليا في
الجراحيه ادرس جراحه
طيب تشرفنا يا اميمه اميمه اريد ان اسالك
اليوم انت بحكم انك لاجئه ربما لا يمكنك
العوده الى ارض الوطن ولكن في ظل ما يحدث
اليوم في السعوديه وفي ظل زمن الانفتاح
والاصلاحات هل تشعرين ربما بالتفاؤل نحو
العوده قريبا ام لا
احيانا يعني تراودني الفكره انه ممكن في
المستقبل تتحسن الاوضاع ممكن نرجع ولكن كل
ما يمر الوقت
المسلسل الاعتقالات مستمر
المحاكمات اللي ضد الناشطات اللي شاركوا
في حمله القياده مستمره ممنوعين من السفر
الى الان نشاطهم على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي محدود
يخليني اشك اذا
الانفتاح هذا او التغيير حيوصل لمرحله
تخلينا نقدر نرجع للسعوديه
وبالثقه الكافيه للعوده دون التعرض
لانتهاك طيب ابقي معي سنتعرف على فاطمه
القصاب من دبلن في ايرلندا فاطمه اهلا بك
انت ناشطه حقيقيه وايضا لاجئه في ايرلندا
اسال نفس السؤال اليوم في ظل هذه الحقبه
الجديده التي تعيشها المملكه هل لديك امل
بالعوده ربما
اهلا وسهلا فيكم سعيده جدا بالمشاركه
الحقيقه انه
اشبه ما يكون
بالامل انه ممكن في يوم من الايام ممكن
اشم رائحه هذا هذه التراب في يوم من
الايام لكن انا لا اظن ان هذا الشيء يكون
نتيجه هذه
ما تصعب بالاصلاحات لانه انا احب وطني لكن
واتمنى اني اقعد لا لكن لا اعول بالكثير
من الاعمال على النظام الحالي او على
الرابعه من نيويورك دانا المعيوف نشط
حقيقيه دانا انت لا يمكنك العوده الى
السعوديه حاليا بسبب يعني رفض تجديد اصلا
جواز السفر ولكن في حال يعني هذا الامر
حصل
ولديك الامكانيه هل تعتبرين ان الوقت
مناسب اليوم في هذه الظروف السياسيه
المتغيره
بالعوده الى المملكه طبعا في ظل وجود
الحكم الحاليه اللي قاعد تصير لله
والملاحقه ايضا
ناشطين خارج المملكه
مستحيل اني ارجع للوطن حتى لو تم تجديد
جوازي انا كنت ابغى الجواز يتجدد بس مش
عشان اسافر للسعوديه لانه انا اعتبر يعني
وعفوا على استخدام هذا المصطلح بس انا
اعتقد حاليا اعتبر الرجوع او العوده
للسعوديه انتحار للاسف طيب
اليوم نتعرف عليها رنا الاحمد ناشطه
حقيقيه ونسويه رنا انت ولدتي في الرياض
وعشتي في الرياض حتى عام 2015 العام الذي
انتقلت فيه الى المانيا واستقريتي في
المانيا
وتربطك طبعا بالسعوديه وبالرياض ذكريات
طفوله والشباب وما الى هنالك عندما
تشاهدين اليوم من المانيا ما يحدث في
المملكه هل تشعرين انك يوما ما قد تعودين
الى هذا هذا الوطن الذي ولدت فيه لا اعتقد
ذلك
الانتقادات والامور اللي انشر على
السوشيال ميديا والتحدث بصدق بالنسبه الي
عن وضع المراه او عن وضع الانسان بين
الدوله ما بيسمح بالعوده لانه الانسان لما
ينتقد او يحكي عن اي شيء بالسعوديه يعني
اذا كان داخل السعوديه بسجن او بيتم
اعتقاله اذا كان خارج السعوديه
بالنسبه الي طيب سننتقل الى النقاش محمد
بن سلمان هو قائد وبطل البعض ومشروع
ديكتاتور بعيون اخرين سنرى او سنستمع الى
كيف يراه الراي العام في بعض العواصم
العربيه ونناقش
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من خلال معناها
حكيمها انها تحب تخرج معناها عن
التموقعها القديم وتظهر في العالم كقائدا
للافضل العربي منظومه استراتيجيه كبيره من
سمو سيدي ولي العهد وكذلك
المشاريع الكبيره اللي موجوده بالفعل
تواكب النهضه الكبيره اللي موجوده في
المملكه وعم يشتغل يعني انه الزلمه بحب
بلده يعني
عقليته شبابيه وعمل انفتاح كانو قبل
يسافروا ليحضروا اشياء
عنده الاقتصاد وكل هالخبريات اكيد طبعا هو
عايز العلاقه في حته التانيه العالميه من
حيث المهرجانات والحفلات اللي بيعملها
يعني انا شايف ان الاصلاحات ديت مش هي ديت
اللي هتحطه على الطريق فبالعكس هذا
الانفتاح اللي عم يبين عليه
عم بيغير الصوره النمطيه تبع السعوديه
يعني وبعتقد انه كل المجتمع عم يتقبلوا
وبما انها يعني اهل مكه ادرى بشعابها لينا
الهذلول محمد بن سلمان رجل طموح شاب يتبنى
التغيير كما يقول هل برايك هو صادق في هذه
الطروحات وكيف ترين هذا الانفتاح الذي
يحدث اليوم في بلدك
اعتقد ان محمد بن سلمان رجل فعلا طموح لكن
لمصالح هو فقط ليس لمصالح الشعب
التغيرات او الاصلاحات كما يسميها البعض
ظاهريه لان لا يمكن لمجتمع او لبلد ان
يتغير فعلا حقيقه يعني جدريا بدون مؤسسات
وبدون الشعب نفسه بمشاركه الشعب
ان اعتقد ابرز مثال هو مثال اختي اختي
كانت من ابرز الناشطات
حاربنا
الولايه
شاركنا
بهشتاغات لمناصره المراه
المراه والقياده
وبالنهايه اعتقلت
ارهابيه اتهمت بالخيانه العظمى الخيانه
العظمى وكارهابيه وتحرشوا فيها جنسيا
واعداءوها فاعتقد ان هذه التغيرات
الاصلاحات جدا ظاهريه
وما تشمل
الاساسيات اللي الشعب السعودي يحتاجها
الان اللي هي الحقوق الاساسيه طيب اميمه
نجار هناك بعض من يرى اليوم ان محمد بن
سلمان رغم رغم كل شيء هو يحاول هو يحاول
وانه يعني يواجه ايضا مقاومه من داخل
المجتمع السعودي لان هناك بعض الطيارات
المحافظه التي ربما لا تريد هذا التغيير
من اساسي
لنتحدث عن تغيير سطحي هل ترين الامور ايضا
بهذا الشكل انا اعتقد التغييرات هذه هي
تغطيه للانتهاكات والاعتقالات التعسفيه
والاعدامات الجماعيه خلال الفتره اللي
احنا نشوف فيها المهرجانات والحفلات برضو
في تثبت انه
العدد الناس اللي اهاجموا باعدادات جماعيه
فوق كل الارقام
حول هذا الموضوع كنت اقرا منظمه ريف تحدثت
عن حوالي اكثر من 120 اعدام عام 2022
خلال هذه الفتره اعدموا ناس حتى جثثهم لم
تسلم لاهاليهم من ضمنهم حقوقيين نشطاء ناس
شاركوا في المظاهرات في فتره الربيع
العربي في 2011 في المنطقه الشرقيه من
الاقليه الشيعيه
اهلهم حتى ما اعطوا خبر انه حيتم الاعدام
في التاريخ الفلاني حتى يودعوا
ابنائهم
في نفس الوقت في حمله تعتقالات مستمره
يعني مثل ما ذكرت
لينا بخصوص سلمى شهاب اكثر من 30 سنه محمد
بن سلمان يغطي فقط ليغطي على هذا تحسين
امام المجتمع الغربي بالمرتبه الاولى
وتغطيه
للانتهاكات والجرائم يعني هي بدات تكثر
حتى بعد اغتيال جمال خاشقجي على طول بدات
المهرجانات وهيئه الترفيه والحفلات بشكل
مكثف حتى
ينشغلوا الاخبار بهذه التغييرات عن محاكمه
الاشخاص اللي تورطوا في اغتيال جمال
خاشقجي
بالنسبه للمجتمع السعودي مجتمع محافظه
اعتقد ان هذا ليست دقيق ليس تقييم دقيق
كنت اريد ان اتحدث عن هذا
بالضبط الكلمه ليستخدمها تستخدمها السلطه
[موسيقى]
سياستها في مسعوديه في ليبرايين في
يساريين في محافظين في مدينين فيه من كل
شيء شعب متنوع متنوع طبعا مع كل الشعوب
الاخرى كان كل بالاخرى وما هي كتله واحده
فاعتقد انه يعني
لازم ما يدور حول هل الشعب يتقبل ام لا هو
لازم يكون حول القمع هل يتقبل القمح ان
الشعب يتقبل ام لا هذا هو السؤال الاساسي
ساكمل عن محمد بن سلمان وسنعود عن مساله
القمع لماذا اليوم هناك صمت ربما في
الداخل الى حد ما على هذه المسائل ربما
خوفا ايضا من التبعات دانيال المعروف محمد
بن سلمان اليوم هناك الكثير من يعني من
الناس المنتمين الى شريحه الشابه في
السعوديه حسب ما راينا في تقارير اعلاميه
ينظرون اليه كبطل او كمثال لهذا القائد
الذي سينهض بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه نحو
الانفتاح والحداثه انت كمعارضه اليوم
الا يمكن ان تري في مكان ما من زاويه ما
هذا الامر ابدا
صراحه مثل ما قالت الاخت لينا
الموضوع بشكل عام
اشوف في تغييرات اشوف في طموح اشوف في
محاوله لتعديل وضع المراه لكن هذا كله
بالاخير يصب مصلحه او تبييض سمعه محمد بن
سلمان لان برايي يعني كناشطه سعوديه يعني
امراه من هذا المجتمع او من هذا البلد لو
كان التغيير او الاستخدام المراه
وتحسين اوضاع المراه في السعوديه بدون
مؤسسات بدون مشاركه المجتمع بدون مشاركه
النساء نفسهم
فكيف انت قاعد تقول انك انت قاعد تساعد
نساء البلد اخر حادثه صارت لحد الان ماثره
فينا احنا كناشطات حقوقيات هي اللي حدث
الايتام خميس مشيط النساء اللي تم ضربهم
امام الجميع شفناهم يتم ضربهم وتم يعني
اذيتهم نفسيا وجسديا لكن اذا كانت
الحكومه السعوديه واحنا نتمنى هالشي احنا
يعني نتمنى ان الحكومه السعوديه من جد
تريد ان تدعم المراه وتحمي المراه من لو
كان هذا الموضوع صحيح لماذا تبقى مع الصوت
النساء وتمت محاسبتهم مين اللي صورت
بالجوال كان هذا السؤال بدل من اللي سمح
دخول
الشرطه السعوديه وضرب البنات وكيف هذا كان
ما حتى حسب منهم اللي تحاسبه هو مين اللي
صور ونشر بالسوشال ميديا فهذا يثبت ان
كورونا صحيح لما نقول ان محمد بن سلمان
فقط يرتبط سمعته هو شخص اناني فقط يريد
تبييض سمعته طيب فاطمه القصاب توافقين على
هذه الفكره ام ان لديك يعني راي مختلف
من المضحك جدا في وجهه نظري ان السعوديه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه رفضت رفض قاطع
التوقيع على اتفاقيات
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان بحجه ان
دستورنا الشريعه الاسلاميه وهذا الكلام
ليس قديما يعني هذا الكلام فقط يعني قبل
بدايه العام الجديد قامت السعوديه برفض
توقيع على اتفاقيات حقوق الانسان
فان التحرر اي ان الانفتاحيه اين يعني
ولكن قد يقول البعض ان الامور تبدا بخطوات
ربما يعني بسيطه وقد تذهب الى ابعد من ذلك
لكن المشكله بالنسبه لان الحاكم الان هو
قاعد يقول بان المجتمع هو المتزنت وهو
المحافظ وهو الرافض للتغيير وهذه كذبه
كبيره وهذه اهانه للمجتمع السعودي انا في
وجهه نظري لان المجتمع السعودي ما هو اللي
قطع راس نفسه لمده ثلاث مئه سنه ما هو
اللي كان يعني يمارس الادلهجه الدينيه
الارهاب الديني على نفسه كل هذه السنوات
هذا كان فعل نتيجه فعل هذه المؤسسه
السياسيه التي سيستت الدين الاسلامي وقامت
بقمع ليس فقط اللاتينيين قامت بتقسيم
المجتمع للعديد من الاقليات ليكره كل واحد
منهم الاخر ولتقوم هذه السلطه بتشليح جميع
الاقليه ضد بعضها البعض باستخدام
حيكت خصيصا
للتغطيه على الجرائم
وصنع الكراهيه بين الناس
هذا واضح جدا ولكن اليوم وسؤالي لك رنا ما
الذي يفسر اليوم ان هناك تقارير كثيره
تشير الى شعبيه هائله لدى محمد بن سلمان
ليس فقط في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وايضا في العالم العربي
على قاعده انه يعني يعني يمكن اليوم لاي
شاب في العالم العربي ان يرى نفسه في محمد
بن سلمان
في الصوره الخارجيه التي تعكس بالاعلام او
او خليني اوضح بشكل ابسط الحكومه السعوديه
بتنفق اموال كثيره عشان صورتها بالخارج ان
كان خارج كدول الغربيه بالداخل الشباب
الجيل الحالي اللي هو عم يستمتع الان
بالحفلات وعم يروح يحضر وعم يروح يسهر
ومبسوط انه صار في حفلات ممكن ما في ثقافه
كافيه يعرف انه شو صار بالحكومه شو هو
تاريخ الحكومه من منظور محايد مانو من
منظور الحكومه او حدا عم يروي القصه من
منظوره هو فاكيد هون ممكن ينبسطوا انا ليش
ازعل انا بالعكس مبسوط على محمد بن سلمان
مسوي حفله ريستا جاي لاسماء الكبيره اكيد
راح نروح ونفرح ونرقص ونغني بس تعالي
اسالي الاغلبيه العظمى هل انت سعيد بالوضع
الحالي للسعوديه هل في اي ازمات اقتصاديه
عم تمثل السعوديه بسبب الحرب خاضت على
اليمن او حاليا بسبب القرارات الطائشه من
محمد بن سلمان
فبتوقع الانخداع هو الانخداع لانه كان في
حفلات بالسعوديه اذا الصوره التي تغطي كما
قالت منذ قليل اميمه يعني هي هي
خارجيه ولكن الداخل هو نظام على الارض
هناك اسلحات حصلت قانونيا في القوانين
هناك تغييرات هناك اوقف العمل الشرطه
الدينيه اعتقل بعد رجال الدين حاول يقول
انه يكافح الفساد سنرى كيف يرى الراي
العام بعد عيد يعني هذه الاصلاحات ثم نعود
اصلاحات في السعوديه في الفتره الاخيره
حاجه كويسه جدا بالنسبه للرياضه والسياحه
بالذات اي اصعب ان واحد يعمل اصلاحات يخلي
المرض سوء او يعمل مثلا
ديسكوات اغاني ومع اغاني واذا واحد حقيقي
كلمه عطا رايه بيحطوا بالحبس وبيعظمه مثلا
الانفتاح هذا الرؤيه هذه والتمشي المنهجي
مبادره شرق الاوسط الاخضر من شانهم ان
يحطوا السعوديه على خط الحداثه الحقيقي لا
لا هذه لحتى
شوي يجيبوا سواح على سعوديه او حتى ليفجر
العالم انه سعوديه صارت هلا منفتحه صار
عندها سنه المراه بالسعوديه عندها حريه بس
لا انا بشوفها هيدا الامور سطحيه كتير
والحمد لله والشكر انه صارت كان حلم
النخبه الثقافيه السعوديه خاصه والعربيه
عامه الدول العربيه الكل
على جميع النواحي معنا الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه
عمرها ما هتضع السعوديه في قياده العالم
العربي السعوديه في قياده العالم العربي
بالحرم ما دون ذلك قياده العالم العربي في
مصر وهدناها في مصر مدى الحياه اهل مكه
اميمه النجار اليوم هناك اصلاحات وقد
يعتبر البعض ممن يرى من الخارج يعني لا
يعرف الكثير عن السعوديه يقول يعارضون من
اجل المعارضه لماذا تعارضون اليوم ماذا
تريدون المعارضه هي مطالبه بالحقوق مش
المعارضه من اجل المعارضه السجون مليئه
بالمثقفين بالاطباء
خبراء اقتصاديين ناس ابدو راي
اعتقلوا بشكل تعسفي حكموا بالارهاب هذه مش
معارضه هذه مطالبه بالحقوق لما احنا نطالب
انه يكون عندنا حريه تعبير انه يكون في
تمثيل لجميع طوائف الشاب بدون اقصاء مثل
ما حصل في الحفلات مؤخرا لما علق رئيس
هيئه الترفيه الشيخ وقال انه العمامه
الحجازيه مثلا لا تمثل ثقافه الحجاز وهي
دخيله من الهند وهي في الحقيقه حجازيه
وكان محاولات تقليب رايي
وتقسيم بين الناس بين نجدي وحجازي هذه
الاشياء موجوده في السعوديه فاحنا نطالب
بتمثيل
حريه الراي النظام بشكل مباشر وشكل النظام
الذي اعتدنا ان نرى عليه السعوديه
كيف يعني يعني اليوم هل يسمح شكل النظام
الحالي في السعوديه باحداث التغيير الذي
تتحدثين عنه لا نعتقد ممكن
بس لما يكون محمد بن سلمان هو على يعني
على كرسي
الحكومه ما حيصير هو يبقى يكون القائد
الوحيد هو رئيس كل شيء في الدوله رئيس كل
الجهات في الدوله فيتحكم بكل القرارات فهو
ما يتقبل الراي حتى من اقربائه وانت ذكرتي
في بدايه التقرير في البرنامج حادثه هو
اعتقل كثير من الامراء كثير من
القاده اللي كانوا موجودين ولهم من ضمنهم
رئيس الحرس الوطني وابناء الملك عبد الله
الوليد بن طلال والى اخره فهو ما يبقى اي
احد ينافس وما يبقى اي احد يختلف معاه
بالري فصعب انه في الوقت الحالي هذه
الاشياء تكون ممكنه اذا بيضل يختزل القوه
والسلطه لذاته فقط
لنرى توافقين على هذا المعطى اليوم
التغيير متاح في شكل النظام في السعوديه
ولكن ليس مع بن سلمان
اتفق
واتفق انه في في مجال للتغيير في المملكه
العربيه نريد الناس اليوم يريد الشعب
السعودي ان يقوم بتغيير ابعد من مساله
يعني عن تغيير التي تتحدثون عنه تغيير
حقوقي تغيير عليه بحريه التعبير يريد هناك
هذه المطالب الاولويه عند الشعب السعودي
لولا
هذه المطالب يعني السجون مليئه معتقلين
راي وهذا يعني
المثال انه
السجون مليئه الراي والشعب هو
يعرفون عنهم لانه يعني شاهدنا الكثير من
التقارير حيث نسال الصحفي او الصحفيه
الفتيات او الشبان تعرفون مثلا عن لوجين
او عن اسماء اخرى من الناشطات والناشطين
ويقولوا لا داخل السعوديه
هناك خوف في خوف في السعوديه ما حد يقدر
يتكلم عن اي احد يعني ولكن في رغبه في
التغيير في رغبه في التغيير طبعا يعني
احنا اي شعب يعني الاولويه حقوقنا وطبعا
ان الشعب السعودي يريد حقوقه اولا طيب
دانه المعيوف اليوم هذه الرغبه بالتغيير
يتحدث عنها الكثر من الخبراء في الشان
السعودي وحتى من الصحفيين الذين عملوا في
المملكه من الاجانب يعتبرون ان هناك
تيارات في المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
المجتمع
ترف هذا الطرح الذين تقومون وتقومن انتن
بطرحه من الخارج على اعتبار ان كنا في
الخارج وانه يعني
التغيير يجب ان يحصل من الداخل وان
المجتمع السعودي لديه ديناميات مختلفه عن
مجتمعات الاخرى ويجب ان يراعي فكره انه
مهد الاسلام وانه ارض مكه وكل ما الى
هنالك كيف تجيبين على هذا النوع من الاراء
بعض يقول انه احنا نعارض لاجل المعارضه او
لاجل النبرز او يعني غير من هذا الكلام
هذا الكلام غير صحيح يعني مثلا انا كناشطه
حقوقيه ايش
النشاط الحقيقي غير اني انا قاعده ادافع
عن اشياء عن اؤمن بها
اللي قاعد يصير في السعوديه الان هو
انتهاك لحقوق الانسان لابسط حقوق الانسان
يعني حتى تغريده بالسوشيال ميديا ممكن
تسبب اعتقالك حتى انك تصور انتهاك
المواطن اخر من مواطن اخر وتحطه بالتويتر
ويصير مثير للجدل ممكن الحكومه تعتقلك بس
لانك شاركت الفيديو هذا فاحنا كمعارضين
نعم لان ابسط الانسان قاعده تنتهك في
البلد وهذا شيء جدا خطير مؤشر خطير احنا
قاعدين قد يصدق الكثيرون اليوم
للاسف ان يعني انكم ربما تنفذون اجندات
لدول غربيه يعني
تعتقدون اجورا او اموالا مقابل ما تقومون
به كيف تدافعون عن نفسكم تريدون ان تدافع
عن نفسكم في هذا الصدد
تفضلي تفضلي
السعوديه بس فقط لديك ما تقولين دانا
فاعود اليك لنلاحظه
تفضل انه انا انا لم محاوله الحكومه
السعوديه تستخدم
التلاعب النفسي وهو محاوله تخزين الناشطات
في الخارج
واتهامهم بانهم عملاء سفرات وما الى ذلك
لكن انا دائما اقول للحكومه السعوديه اذا
انتم جادين بالاتهام هذا ارفعوا عليه قضيه
يعني انا خائنه للبلد لانه انا مستعده
اقدم لكم كل ايصالات كل حساباتي البنكيه
اذا فيها ريال او الدولار واحد من منظمه
خارجيه عشان اطلع اتكلم بالتلفزيون وقتها
انا فعلا خائنه لكن انا متاكده اضمن هذا
الكلام انه احنا كلنا اللي طالعين رحنا
قاعدين نتكلم لاننا من جد نحب الوطن من جد
نبغى مصلحه الوطن مش مصلحه
فتم القصه اعود اليك لن فاطمه اريد ان
اسمع رايك في هذا الاطار اليوم
في الواقع عندي ملاحظه وهي
الحكومه السعوديه ما تهتم للمجتمع السعودي
ابدا ومن مصلحتها اصل اصلا انها مو انها
تمكن الشعب سواء كان امراه او رجل او طفل
او كان بروفيسور او عالم او اقتصادي او
عالم دين او عالم اقتصاد او علم سياسه كل
هذه الفئات او مهندسين حتى كل هذه الفئات
اذا كنت انت سعودي في داخل السعوديه
الدوله من مصلحتها انها تهمشك انها يعني
تعطلك انها يعني تعطل مسارك من الامثله هي
صحيفه عقاب نشرت بان هناك كثير من اكثر من
35,000 مهندس سعودي عاطل عن العمل هذه
الاعداد ما كانت
لكن هذه الاعداد ما كانت انا متاكده من
الارقام لكن عدد كبير من المهندسين
السعوديين عاطينا للعمل بينما المنظمه
الهيئه السعوديه للمهندسين يوجد فيها اكثر
من 155 الف مهندس مستخدم خلو نتكلم عن يوم
مثلا او مشروع ذا لاين اللي بني على انقاذ
الحويطات وعلى انقاب التهجيل القصري الذي
حصل والقتل الذي حصل والاعتقال الذي حصل
لاهلها هذه المنطقه على الاقل لما انت
عملت مشروع تقدمي
وظف سعوديين وظف ناس من اهل البلد لدينا
الكثير من الامكانيات لان الكثير من
الخبرات ولكن ما حصل هو عمل تعاقد تعاقد
مع اجانب قاموا في النهايه يعني بالرحيل
ولم يقوموا بالعمل وحتى عبروا وصرحوا
بانهم فقط ارادوا ان يعني يسرقوا الملايين
ويذهب بدون ان يعني يضطروا للعمل في بيئه
مثل بيئه
شكرا فاطمه رنا اريد ان اسالك هناك ما
استوقفنا ايضا عندما
خصوصا الاجندات الخارجيه الى اخره بس نشوف
قضيه اختي مثلا قالوا عنها انها خاينه
وانها نافذه جنات
واضح يعني ما في اي شيء
تخبيها المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم
تقول
للمواطن السعودي نشاطك الحقوقي بنعتبره
ارهاب علي هل هناك لا ادري يعني صححنا لي
لو كان لو كانت معلومه خاطئه ولكن حسب ما
قرات ان هناك في القانون قانون امن الدوله
لعام 61 في السعوديه عقوبات تصل حد
الاعدام على كل من يعارض النظام ويمارس
اعمالا سياسيه حزبيه بشكل عام يعني يعني
المعارضه ممنوعه في المملكه العربيه بشكل
عام قانونيا طيب سؤالي لك رنا كان وما هو
ايضا ملفاتنا عندما عندما قرانا لنعد لهذه
الحلقه هناك
انطباع لدى من يراقب ان هناك استهداف
للنساء السعوديه المعارضات المقيمات في
الخارج بشكل اكبر من الرجال هل هذا صحيح
الذي ملاحظه صحيحه هذا ممكن يعني ان تكون
ربما السيدات في المجد تحت المجهر بشكل
اكبر لان هنا سيدات ربما ولكن من منظور
نحن نعلم في دول الغرب عندما تتحدث امراه
عن حقوق المراه او عن تجربتها خلال خلال
رحلتها الى بلد الحريه يكون التركيز اكثر
على النساء من التركيز على الرجال بسبب ان
دول الغرب تدعم حقوق المراه وترغب بالتحدث
بهذا الامر
ولكن اعتقد انه
التركيز حسب النشاط هل صوتك مسموع اكثر هل
لديك متابعين بالالاف او بالملايين اكثر
تاثير التاثير تاثير
الحكومه السعوديه عندما تركز على شخص
بقتله او تهديده او او عمل اي امر سيء لا
يكون تركيز ما هو تاثيره كم شخص يتابعه كم
شخص يسمعه كم شخص يتاثر منه
اميمه ما هي المملكه العربيه السعوديه
التي تحلمين بها متى يعني تقولين لنفسك
اعود الى وطني في حال في حال ماذا انا
ابغى اعقب على السؤال
هو اول حراك حقوقي ناجح في السعوديه
فمن الطبيعي جدا انه السلطه السعوديه تخاف
من اصوات النساء في الفتره الماضيه من
تاسست السعوديه كان في احزاب طلبت
بالدستوريه
بالديمقراطيه في احزاب اقليات طلبوا
ينفصلوا ولكن لاول مره
باختلافنا من الحجاز الى الشرقيه من
الجنوب الى نجد الى الشمال اتفقنا كلنا
كنيسه نبقى حقوقنا وكان في صوت واحد فهذا
طبعا نجح طبعا وهذه النشاط الحقوقي نجح
ونتج عنه الوضع الحالي وبعض الحقوق الفتات
الحقوق اللي حاليا السعوديه تعطيها لبعض
النساء مش كلهم لانه بعضهم
بعض النساء وهذا لافتنا ايضا على ما يبدو
يعني هذه الاصلاحات لا تطال او لا تلامس
كل شرائح المجتمع السعودي هل هذا صحيح
طبعا
في نساء اللي شاركوا النشاط الحقوقي
ممنوعين من حق السفر مثلا بينما نزل قانون
انه المراه الان تستطيع تجديد جواز سفرها
داخل السعوديه طبعا باستثناء دينا
باستثناءنا احنا باستثناء الناشطات
الحقوقيات
الموجودات في البلد ممنوعين من السفر
الحقوق ما كانت كامله
زي ما قلت لك هو النساء اجتمعوا كصوت واحد
واعطى تاثيرها
يفسر تركيز الكبير على يعني تهديد وملاحقه
المعارضات في الخارج بشكل اساسي طيب اميمه
سؤالي الاخير يعني لكنا ساسال الجميع
اليوم عندما تفكرين بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه تريدين تقولين احلم بها بهذا
الشكل كيف هو شكل هذه المملكه فيها تكون
بلد ديمقراطي يمثل فيه جميع الاحزاب بكل
توجهاتهم سواء سواء بالاختلافات الثقافه
في الدين في
من اي جهه من اي يكون فيها حق للمراه
موازي للرجل ما يكون راتب المراه نص راتب
الرجل وهذا في الوضع الحالي في السعوديه
وهذه احصاء احصائيات الحكومه يعني مش احنا
جايبين ارقام من عندنا اذا كان راتب الرجل
عشره الاف راتب المراه خمسه الاف في نفس
الوظيفه في نفس
الكواليفيكيشن او درجه الدراسه يعني يكون
فيها حقوق متساوي للجميع من الكلام الصريح
اميمه عندما تتكلمين على التلفزيون او على
منصات التواصل او تكتبين الا تشعرين
بالخوف ربما من هذا الواقع الصعب
من التهديدات انا انا اعتقد نفسي ما احس
بالخوف لاني خارج البلد يمكن لو كنت داخل
البلد كان ممكن اخاف رغم اني كنت استخدم
اسمي الشخصي فلما كنت ادون داخل البلد
يعني لكن
لا عندي امل انه هذه الاصوات وهذا العمل
الحقوقي الى التغيير الذي ترغبين ان ترى
بلدك عليه ايوه طيب
رنا الاحمد اليوم يعني لديك ذكريات في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تقولين اعود الى
المملكه في حال في حال ماذا دوله مدنيه
دوله لها دستور بالمقام الاول وجود دستور
للدوله من اهم الاشياء اللي ممكن انه يعمل
دوله ديمقراطيه علمانيه ليبراليه
ليس الان ولكن دوله مدنيه دوله لها دستور
والدستور يكون منتخب عن طريق الشعب الشعب
اللي يقرر مثلا نحن بدنا بنود الدستور
الحالي او اللي تم تطويره ويتم بناء دوله
مدنيه دوله مدنيها في الدستور فيها شرطه
وفيها حكومه
لنا الهذول عائلتك في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اليوم اي يخيفك يعني انت جريئه
مثل كل السيدات اليوم الحاضرات معنا الا
تخافين من
الانتقاد من المعارضه وما الذي يدفعك الى
استكمال هذه الرحله طبعا اخاف طبيعي هذه
ممنوعين من السفر اختي اعتقلت عدبوها لكن
كل هذا حصل وحنا بالخارج ما تكلمناه كنا
صامتين اصلا ما اعطونا الخيار
يعني انا احس اني مجبوره الان اني اتكلم
مجبور اني ادافع عن اهالي عن عن عن شعبي
عن ناسي يعني ما عطاني الخيار صراحه فطبعا
اخاف لكن يعني بدون كلام وبدون كل كل
النشاط هذا اعتقد انه ممكن يكون الوضع
اسود
طيب فاطمه القصاب
اعود الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه في حال
ممكن انا حلمي الى المملكه هو انه نتخلص
او نتجرد من السلطويه المتفشيه في كل
انواع نواحي الحياه في السعوديه مو بس على
مستوى الدوله او على مستوى السياسه في عنا
صوت طويل دينيه اجتماعيه من كل النواحي
الفرد السعودي ما عنده اي نوع من انواع
الاطعمه او الفردانيه لكن انا اشوف انه
هذه من اكثر الاشياء اللي تهدد مو بس يعني
الحريه حقت الفرد السعودي بس ايضا اخلاق
المجتمع السعودي فانا
عدوته السلطه
شكرا لك فاطمه دانا المعروف اختم معك
اليوم
اريدك ان تقولي لنا عن الخوف هل يلازمك
الخوف ربما في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بسبب مواقفك وما الذي قد يعيدك الى
المملكه ما هي المملكه التي تحلمين بان
تكوني مواطنه مقيمه فيها
بالنسبه للخوف الخوف حقيقي واضح وموجود
للاسف حتى وانا في امريكا
يعني الشرطه نيويورك دخلوا البيت عندنا
وحطونا جهاز حمايه يعني الشرطه في نيويورك
ما راح تتدخل اذا كان الموضوع مش جدي او
التهديدات مش جديه
للاسف يعني اكيد كسعوديه يعني وحده انولدت
في السعوديه او عاشت في السعوديه اكيد اني
اتمنى اعيش او ارجع اشوف يعني خليني اقول
صعب ارجع اعيش لانه الان انا كونت عائله
هنا بس اكيد ابغى ازور ازور بلدي ابغى
ادخل ازور بلدي بدون ما احس بخوف ابغى
ادخل القنصليات بلدي اجدد معاملاتي بدون
ما احس بخوف ابغى اخذ زوجي اللي هو من
دوله اخرى يرجع للسعوديه ويشوف البلد
ويشوف التغيرات والتطورات لكن للاسف حاليا
ما اقدر ارجع السعوديه راح ارجع للسعوديه
اذا تغير تنظيم او تشكيل الحكومه اذا تم
فصل القضاء عن الدوله او المسؤولين اذا في
قبره قدره للمواطن السعودي انه يحاسب
المسؤولين اما الان الوضع في السعوديه
صراحه يعني دوله كالغابه
المسؤول يعني ممكن يعتقلك حتى على كل ما
كلمه بسيطه فاكيد اني شكرا دانا اريد منك
اميمه كلمه اخيره اليوم يعني انت على منبر
اليوم عليك ان تقولي ما شئت
لمن شئت ماذا تقولين
كلمه اخيره اختصار كنت
في الخارج اللي ما نعرفهم
انه
يستمروا بالنشاط الحقوقي وانه ينضموا
للنشاط الحقوقي وانه في امل مثل ما قدروا
النساء انه يغيروا ويحدثوا هذا التغيير
الحالي ولو كان بسيط نقدر نسوي تغيرات
اخرى واكبر مو بس فيه حقوق المراه ولكن
على مستوى سياسيا مع هذا الامل نختم هذه
الحلقه من برنامج فلك الممنوع كما غنت
فيروز وقالت يا قارئ القران صلي لهم واهلي
هناك وطيب البيدا النقاش الفلكي الممنوع
لا نهايه له نتركه لك ولك حريه التعبير
وحريات الاختيار الى اللقاء في حلقات
جديده على
الدوليه تحياتي
[موسيقى]